après la découverte des dizaines de
corps de civils dans la ville de butch à
bruxelles veut marquer le coup un
cinquième paquet de sanctions pour
accroître la pression sur moscou
parmi celles proposées par la commission
européenne aux pays membres de l'ue eux
l'interdiction de toutes les
importations de charbon en provenance de
russie une source d'énergie plus facile
à remplacer que le pétrole ou le gaz
russe autre proposition l'arrêt total
des transactions avec quatre grandes
banques russes représentant un quart du
secteur bancaire du pays ou encore
l'interdiction des navires russes dans
les ports européens sauf ceux
transportant des produits essentiels ou
de l'aide humanitaire clients les
clairement au vu des événements nous
devons encore augmenter notre pression
sotoudeh
nous proposons donc aujourd'hui d'aller
plus loin dans nos sanctions nous allons
les élargir et les rendre plus précises
pour qu'elle touche encore plus
profondément l'économie russe
pour que les sanctions soient adoptées
les états membres de l'union européenne
doivent les voté à l'unanimité les
représentants des 27 discuteront des
propositions ce mercredi avant une
rencontre lundi prochain entre les
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'union du côté des états unis même
volonté de durcir une nouvelle fois le
ton contre moscou washington va
interdire ce mercredi tout nouvel
investissement en russie pour cela les
autorités vont renforcer les sanctions
contre les institutions financières les
entreprises publiques russes ainsi que
contre des responsables gouvernementaux
et leurs proches
la plus grande partie de notre objectif
est d'épuiser les ressources dont
poutine dispose pour poursuivre sa
guerre contre l'ukraine est évidemment
créer plus d'incertitudes et de défis au
système financier russe fait partie de
ceux là
selon une source américaine l'économie
russe devrait se contracter d'au moins
15% 2022 sous l'effet de la guerre en
ukraine et des sanctions occidentales
une récession qui effacerait les progrès
économiques fait par la russie ces 15
dernières années
tout à l'heure à la tribu